In part one of this series, I spent time in
the village of Nabi Saleh in the Occupied
West Bank, home to Palestinian teenager, Ahed Tamimi.
She slapped an Israeli soldier in front of her home,
and became a worldwide symbol of Palestinian resistance.
Now 17 years old, Ahed grew up regularly confronting
Israeli soldiers who raided her village.
The soldiers' efforts to suppress the villagers’
nonviolent protests were
captured in videos that went viral on social media.
After 8 months locked up by Israel, Ahed and her mother are finally being released,
on a day of total chaos and heightened emotions,
I sat down with Ahed to hear her experience, and ask what lies ahead for the Palestinian teen icon.
So it’s a little after 4 am on the day Ahed’s going to be released. And we’re in Nabi Saleh
meeting her family right now.
This is the day the family has been awaiting for 8 months. The release of Ahed, and her mother, Nariman,
who filmed her daughter’s confrontation with the Israeli soldiers and was charged with incitement.
For days, the family has been preparing for the homecoming,
and camera crews have had a constant presence around the house.
Israeli authorities provided little information about where they’d release the mother and daughter.
Bassem has heard different accounts from journalists who heard from Israeli prison authorities
that they’d be dropped off at a checkpoint called Jbara, near the Hasharon prison where they’ve been jailed.
It’s an hour and a half away by car.
We were on our way to the checkpoint near Tulkaram, which is about an hour and a half away.
They got a phone call saying it’s gonna be at the Rantis checkpoint. We’re at the Rantis checkpoint
right now and they just got a call saying no, they’re going to be released from the first checkpoint.
There’s absolutely no clarity and it almost feels like deliberate confusion
that they don’t know where exactly she’ll be dropped off and released.
After two and half hours of driving, we were told once again to turn around and head back to Rantis.
We're by the Rantis checkpoint waiting for the release of Ahed and her mom
and an apparent settler has come to protest with his Israeli flag.
An Israeli military vehicle just drove by that they believe her and her mom are in, but it went that way
so now everybody is getting in their cars to follow them. Like I said, this is complete confusion.
We're going to Nabi Saleh.
This is total chaos right now.
Ahed was finally released.
But the soldiers still hadn’t released Nariman.
So we just saw Nariman get out right there. The relatives are hugging her.
Their first steps of freedom were taken to visit the home of 21-year-old Izz Addine Tamimi,
a relative who was shot and killed by an Israeli soldier while they were in prison.
They went to give their condolences to his mother.
The family is holding a press conference right now. Ahed and her mother,
Nariman, will be giving statements and then they'll be  answering questions of journalists.
I met Ahed on her first morning of freedom.
Hey guys, it's Dena Takruri in Nabi Saleh in the Occupied West Bank. Be sure to follow more Direct From episodes
I'll be reporting on more indigenous and land issues.
Also make sure you subscribe to AJ+. Like, comment and share this video.